let's explore the bootstrap
documentation for the grid system these
first three lines are really important
the first one says that all rows must be
placed within a container or a fluid
container this allows them to have the
right alignment and padding on the page
will also be using rows to create
horizontal groups of columns which means
columns that are lined up one next to
each other and this last point says that
your content has to be inside of a
column and a column has to be inside of
a row back to our mock-up we've gone
ahead and put some boxes around the
different elements on the page we have a
container encompassing the entire page
we've got a row right here in the middle
that includes a pie and sunflower and
then apathy itself is just a single
column inside this row we can see other
examples for instance at the top we have
a header that's going to be a row and
inside of our row we have two columns
one on the left and one on the right